[Music]
what's up everyone Michael here to talk
about the most recent episode of Rick
and Morty Rick a mort well lived this
one has it all Rick starts a new
religion that's absolutely not a
religion Morty's Consciousness gets
shattered into pieces inside a video
game and summer does a die hard but
something else stood out to us and
please just go with me on this one the
episode aired on 911 and we don't think
this is a coincidence it seems like the
episode explores the way in which
religious narratives and mythologies
both shape human culture and seem to
fuel some pretty serious violence now I
know this Probably sounds a little heavy
for an episode that features Peter
Dinklage playing alien obsessed with die
hard it's not every day when meets a
fellow Die Hard Enthusiast but we'll
explain in this wisecrack quick take on
Rick and Morty season 6 episode 2 did
Rick and Morty do a 911 episode first a
quick summary Rick Morty and summer are
at a space arcade that's been taken over
by alien terrorists Morty and Rick are
both inside the video game Roy which
they previously played in season two
holy [ __ ] that's taking Roy Off the Grid
and in which Morty's Consciousness is
stuck spread amongst all the non-roy
characters in The Game Rick as Roy has
to convince all these characters that
they are in fact his grandson in order
to help Morty Escape all the while
summer is holding off the terrorists
after Rick told her to just do a Die
Hard eventually Rick and Morty make it
out they help summer defeat the
terrorists it's all happily ever after
except for the fact that part of um
Morty's Consciousness is now stuck in
the video game Roy that's being wheeled
into a warehouse Indiana Jones style
potentially lost forever but oh boy but
back to Roy the game in which Rick has
to convince all the mortys to accept the
reality that they are grandsons it
quickly turns into a sort of religious
movement he's one of those cult people
they worship some psycho named Roy that
says he's everybody's Grandpa and
despite Rick's best efforts you guys
keep thinking I'm a religious leader
this isn't a religion this is actual
truth I'm a scientist in real life this
all seems to be the Show's way of
pointing out the often arbitrary roots
of various religious movements I feel
like every time I explain this I lose
followers but this isn't a religion and
the eagerness with which people join
them and build a culture around them but
this non-religion religion grandsonism
quickly establishes a type of in-group
out group logic in which those
acknowledging that they are 14 year old
boys who love masturbation are in and
those who remain attached to their video
game selves are out this is of course a
thing that's happened throughout human
history often with less than kosher
consequences get down you're all under
arrest for being religious the wrong way
what starts as a little old-fashioned
social division based on religion
quickly escalates to a full on holy war
which is set off when Rick struggles to
tell Morty that he loves him Rick I'll
get every single part of me to get on
every ship and go with you good but you
have to tell us you love us
I mean at this point even if he said it
what what what's with the pause screw
you wait for it Holy Wars forever I
guess the messages tell people you love
them or you might cause a war the use of
the term holy war doesn't seem to be
accidental as the show is clearly
pointing out how quickly religious
beliefs can become excuses for
large-scale violence and again
um this episode aired on 9 11. and the
show isn't original and making the
argument that religion has an
exceptional ability to incite violence
and War and fittingly some of the most
potent religious narratives that justify
violence are like grandsonism not
explicitly religious per se while some
would frame the war on terror as liberal
democracy versus Islamic fundamentalism
others might see the opposite I.E a
pseudo-theological American nationalism
versus a region of the world devastated
by years of foreign intervention and
military occupation and that's not even
to mention oil production or Dick
Cheney's business friends however the
conventional way that the war on terror
is framed serves an important purpose
according to Theologian William T
Kavanaugh the myth of religious violence
promotes a dichotomy between us and the
secular West who are rational and
peacemaking and them the hordes of
violent religious Fanatics in the Muslim
World their violence is religious and
therefore irrational and divisive our
violence on the other hand is rational
peacemaking and necessary regrettably we
find ourselves forced to bomb them into
the higher rationality so for Kavanaugh
the idea that religion is uniquely
violent is often more of an ideological
function dependent on specific
definitions of what's religion and
what's not used to justify more rational
forms of non-religious violence often
carried out in the name of the state it
seems that the episode might be leaning
into the idea that the seemingly
decades-long holy war between grandson
factions is a reflection of the
absurdity of lots of actually existing
human conflict in which people are
willing to kill or be killed over
disagreements on religious and mythical
narratives it's parenting like this that
pushed me into religious radicalism so
is Rick and Morty using the Holy Wars of
grandsonism to argue that religion is
both a often a totally made up thing
that b is unique in its ability to
create irrational violence
maybe but according to Kavanaugh it's a
mistake to attempt to draw a distinction
between secular and religious violence
we must conclude that there is no
coherent way to isolate religious
ideologies with a peculiar tendency
towards violence from their Tamer
secular counterparts so-called secular
ideologies and institutions like
nationalism and liberalism can be just
as absolutist divisive and irrational as
so-called religion people kill for all
sorts of things the point is not simply
that secular violence should be given
equal attention to religious violence
the point is that the distinction
between secular and religious violence
is unhelpful misleading and mystifying
and should be avoided altogether so
basically it's not that religion is
uniquely violent in history especially
given that according to Kavanaugh the
secular religious dichotomy is a modern
invention rather it's that absolutism
and irrationality are at the heart of
all political violence so unlike the Sam
Harris's and Bill Mars of the world who
argue that Western violence towards the
Islamic world is justifiable due to the
superior rationality of liberal
democracy for Kavanaugh there isn't
really a distinction between so-called
religious and secular violence okay so
if that's the case then why do we still
often associate religion with irrational
violence well for Kavanaugh the myth of
religious violence establishes a
reassuring dichotomy between their
violence which is absolutist divisive
and irrational and our violence which is
modest unitive and rational making the
violence of the other uniquely religious
allows those on the other side to feel
confident that they're violent but like
in a good way there isn't even a God in
the real world you fragmented putts this
also involves the type of absolutism
that both religious and secular violence
have because both sides believe they
have absolute access to some type of
goodness or truth and then they have a
mission to expand the reach of that
goodness or truth and speaking of
goodness and Truth have you checked out
wisecrack live yet it's our new stream
it takes place every Thursday at 11 A.M
Pacific right here on our YouTube page
it's fun we watch videos talk about
what's going on in the world we have a
really fun chat and I really mean that
it's like the best chat on YouTube so
come check it out sometime we would love
to have you there okay so these themes
are also present in summer storyline as
Die Hard has become a foundational myth
across the Galaxy every Sunday
across the Galaxy eventually develops
the same myth in Centauri it's known as
Tower man the oranese have their
Thornburg cycle and an Andromeda is
called foolish to have imagined you'd be
able to kill and the potency of this
myth has clearly led to lots of very
stupid violence instead of handing me an
unloaded gun she'll hand me up
Summer only reads this religious text
when it helps her achieve her goal of
killing aliens you left your book in the
bathroom I read it while I took a [ __ ] I
mean mostly the ending the
quasi-religious mythology of Die Hard is
reduced into a mere conduit for more
violence walkie-talkie Die Hard
[ __ ] so what is the show saying
here on the one hand they might be
pointing out the seeming absurdity of
religion in general and more
specifically its tendency to engender
violence amongst its adherents on the
other maybe they're taking a more broad
approach and showing how in the wake of
events like the 911 attacks politics and
religion can be just too sides of the
same irrationally violent coin better to
die in Roy than to serve in hell as
Kavanaugh concludes this opposition of
rational and irrational secular and
religious Western and Muslim is not
simply descriptive but helps to create
the opposition that it purports to
describe well said William well said but
what do you guys think did Justin roilin
and Co make a cynical holiday episode
for 9 11 or is growing up during the war
on terror just broken my brain please
let us know in the comments thanks as
always to our patrons for your support
and be sure to be a good grandson and
please like this video subscribe to the
Channel all that stuff it means a lot as
always thanks so much for watching and
walkie-talkie Die Hard [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]